SILO:
Hey guys, for those of you who want the summary,
we’re launching an investing app centered
around treasuries and bonds called Silo.
We’ve been working on this app for past
20 months and we’re really excited for you
letting people off the waitlist by the end
of the year.
If you would like to be one of the first people
to get access to Silo, please consider joining
our waitlist below.
For those of you who wanna know more, let
me explain.
WHAT IS SILO?:
Silo is an investing platform that is looking
bring the 21st century to the underappreciated
market of bonds.
If you’re looking to invest in bonds on
any existing platform whether it be Fidelity,
Schwab, or TD Ameritrade, you’ll probably
be greeted with a table that looks like this.
You have an assortment of maturity dates and
bond types but you don’t really get any
information about who the issuers are, what
other bonds they offer, or any bond specific
characteristics.
And if you click one of these table entries,
you’re taken to a page like this where you
just see a massive list of every single bond
on the market that fits the given category.
I would imagine that this is rather overwhelming
for someone who is trying to invest in bonds
for the first time.
And that’s why we wanted to build an experience
that prioritizes the ease of finding and investing
in the issuers you know and trust.
For example, let’s say I wanted to invest
in an Apple bond.
I can easily navigate to the search tab, look
up Apple, and get a list of all Apple bonds
sorted by maturity.
You can also sort by yield, coupon rate, or
our custom suitability score.
For every bond in the app, we use your investment
goals and profile to create a personalized
suitability score.
This Apple bond for example has a suitability
score of 89 and a yield of 5.317%.
You can use this slider to estimate how much
you can expect to earn on a daily, monthly,
and annual basis at the current yield.
And if you scroll down, you can see all of
the traits of the given bond.
Speaking of bond characteristics, if you don’t
have a specific issuer in mind, you can navigate
over to the explore page.
By default, the explore page pulls up 5 bonds
the best match your investment profile but
you can further refine the search.
For example, let’s say, I’m looking for
a corporate investment grade bond that’s
yielding at least 7%.
I can just enter in these requirements, press
filter, and get a list of bonds that meet
my requirements sorted by suitability.
Let’s look for an issuer that we recognize.
Ah here’s one, Paramount Global.
Let’s say I wanna invest $10,000 into Paramount.
I can see that I would earn a little less
than $800 per year.
If I’m feeling good about this, I can go
ahead and and press earn.
From here, I can adjust any of the order settings
that I want.
For example, if I want the order to fill as
quickly as possible, I can change the order
type to market and press submit.
The app asks me to authorize using face id
and there we go, the order is submitted.
Now, if I navigate to the history tab, I can
see my latest order.
It looks like it’s already been filled and
if I go over to my portfolio I can see it
as a new position under Paramount Global.
If I wanna sell, I can do the exact same thing.
Just press sell, change the order type to
market, and press submit.
And boom, my order is submitted.
I can go view my order status on history and
it looks like it’s already been filled,
so if I go back and refresh my position, we
can see that it’s now empty.
And that’s how easy it is to find a bond,
buy it, and sell on Silo.
Lastly, you have your profile page where you
have general house keeping stuff like statements,
settings, profile, and things of that nature.
So, that was kind of a general overview of
Silo, and I hope you would agree that it’s
far friendlier to use than what’s already
out there but that’s not why we created
Silo.
Let me explain.
WHY SILO:
The main reason that we started developing
Silo is because an entire generation of investors
are being left behind: Millennials.
In fact, on average Millennials tend to hold
65% of their assets in cash, the highest of
any generation.
It’s easy to write this off as irresponsible
Millennials who are too busy ordering DoorDash
instead of focusing on investing and their
financial future, but there’s actually a
much darker factor at play: the 2008 financial
crisis.
The 2008 financial crisis affected everyone.
Millions of people lost their jobs, their
homes, and everything they ever worked for
while big banks and irresponsible corporations
got to walk away with massive bailouts.
Wells Fargo: $25 billion, JP Morgan Chase:
$25 billion, Citi Group: another $25 billion,
and those are just the banks.
GE walked away with a $140 billion bailout
and AIG walked away with a $182 billion bailout.
Once again, the real culprits had walked away
scott free while it was the everyday American
that was left behind.
But, despite how painful this was, most Americans
did work through this.
They eventually go new jobs, new houses, and
built up new life savings, everyone except
for Millennials.
Ironically, Millennials had lost the least
amount of money given that they were all young
adults with no money to lose.
But while they didn’t lose money, they had
lost something much more deeper: a part of
the American dream.
They had seen their parents and people around
them lose everything and it gave them a rather
cynical view of capitalism.
They felt that there was no reason to be loyal
to a company, no reason to idolize rich people,
and definitely no reason to invest given that
Wall Street would just stack the cards against
them.
15 years later, these fears are still very
much alive.
In fact, a whopping 80% of Millennials admit
that the crisis still influences their investing
to this day.
And this is largely why they tend to hoard
cash.
In fact, nearly 1 in 4 millennials have savings
of $100,000 or more, yet stock market participation
is still lower than it was 23 years ago.
Several new age investing companies have tried
to address this.
On the stock side of things, you’ve got
people like Robinhood, Webull, Public.com,
MooMoo, and M1 Finance.
And on the crypto side of things, you’ve
got people like Coinbase, Binance, and a lot
more till recently.
But, while these guys have increased market
participation, I don’t think they’ve necessarily
increased investing participation given that
these guys aren’t exactly encouraging people
to invest.
Rather, they’re encouraging people to trade
stocks and options or 10X their money with
crypto.
Much of their pitch is trying to make investing
fun and exciting but the reality is that investing
should not be exhilarating.
If it is, you’re probably gambling, not
investing.
Of course, you’ll always hear about some
random guy who made millions by betting on
some obscure stock or crypto, but chances
are, you probably won't be turning a $1000
into a million by trading.
You’re actually more likely to lose the
initial $1000.
Why do platforms sell this vision then you
ask?
Well, two reasons.
For one, untold riches is the easiest way
to get people to open accounts and deposit
money.
And two, traders generate far more commissions
than buy and hold investors.
And as such, we’ve seen this massive gamification
of the entire investing space.
Real investing, however, isn’t about making
millions overnight.
Real investing is about making responsible
and calculated moves to grow wealth over an
entire lifetime, and this is what we would
like to bring to market with Silo.
WHAT ARE BONDS:
Long term, we would like to offer much more
than just bonds but we decided to start with
bonds because its by far the most underappreciated
and underserved asset class especially when
it comes to everyday investors.
You see, all of the biggest companies and
investors in the world own hundreds of billions
of dollars worth of bonds.
Take Apple for instance.
They’re currently holding $34 billion in
short term marketable securities and $104
billion in long term marketable securities
most of which is bills and bonds.
Similarly, Microsoft is holding $144 billion
in cash, cash equivalents, and short term
investments.
Even Warren Buffett, the legendary stock investor,
is playing with a hundred billion worth of
treasury bills.
All of this is only a mere fraction of the
entire bond market though.
The global bond market is worth $133 trillion
which is even larger than the global stock
market which is “only” worth $109 trillion.
But despite the raw size and ubiquity of bonds,
the everyday investor has only heard about
bonds in passing.
So what even are Bonds?
Well, before we get into all the technical
details, let’s take a step back and understand
the role you play in the bond market.
As an individual, you get the unique opportunity
to help large companies and our government
raise money.
These institutions really only have two main
ways they can raise money: sell parts of their
company or get a loan.
When they sell a part of the company, you’re
able to buy a piece of it through the stock
market.
Now, if you’re the average millennial, you’re
probably not the biggest fan of stock investing
because you saw what happened in 2008.
Any company could very well crash and burn,
rendering their stock completely useless.
After all, didn’t Amazon themselves lose
money for a decade?
- this all sounds a bit too risky, and you’re
not wrong.
Investing in individual stocks can not only
be risky but unpredictable, but this risk
also comes along with a substantial amount
upside potential.
If you’re just looking for a stable reliable
investment that pays out a set amount though,
this may be where bonds could be of value.
Instead of buying a piece of the company,
with bonds, you lend to the company under
a legally binding contract.
And if they don’t pay you back, a bunch
of lawyers would knock down their door and
sell everything they have left to pay you
back as much as possible.
When a company agrees to this arrangement,
they agreeing to raise debt, otherwise known
as issuing bonds.
And these very bonds are available for us
to purchase; however, they work a bit differently
than stocks.
For starters, the most basic characteristic
of a bond is it’s “face value”.
This is usually $1000 and it’s the amount
of money that the company is promising to
you pay you back.
This doesn’t mean that you’ll always buy
a bond at face value though.
Oftentimes, the market price of a bond will
be lower than its face value.
For example, an Apple bond with a face value
of $1000 may be trading at $950.
This means that you only have to pay $950
to purchase this bond but Apple will pay you
back $1000 when the bond matures.
If the bond’s maturity is 1 year out, you’ll
earn a profit of $50 at the end of the year
which translates to roughly a 5% yield.
In the meantime, most bonds will also pay
out interest payments known as “coupon payments”.
A coupon payment is a percentage of the face
value that gets paid out usually twice a year.
For example, let’s say that same Apple bond
had a coupon rate of 2%, well then, on top
of $50 that you already earned, you would
earn another $20 in the form of coupon payments.
Aka, your total profit from the bond would
be $70 meaning that your total yield would
be roughly 7%.
Of course, you could really get into the weeds
of but in a general sense, that’s about
it.
You lend a company a bit of your money, they
pay you some interest for it, and once the
contract is over, they pay you back and go
about their business, but how safe really
is all of this?
COMMITMENT TO SECURITY:
One key features of bonds is their consistent
and predictable interest payments.
Since there is a legal obligation for the
lender to pay you back, failure to make those
timely payments puts lenders in default.
Just like us individuals have credit ratings
that measure how financially responsible we
are, companies have credit ratings that measure
the likelihood of default.
These ratings are split into two categories:
investment-grade and high-yield, or “junk”,
with investment-grade bonds being seen as
the safer of the two.
In fact, in 14 of the past 22 years, investment-grade
corporate bonds did not default AT ALL.
Also, about “junk” bonds, these definitely
have a scary name we wouldn’t personally
recommend these, but all things considered,
they’re actually rather safe as well.
Even with all the talk about inflation and
interest rates for example, as of June, the
high-yield bond default rate was still only
1.9% which just goes to show how seriously
companies take paying back bondholders.
On Silo, there’s over 2,000 corporate issuers
that you can choose from but if you’re really
concerned about minimizing risk, your best
bet would likely be government bills and bonds.
The federal government’s bonds, aka treasuries,
work the same way as any other bond.
However, because the government issues them,
they are seen as some of the safest investments
available.
Now, let me preface by saying that there is
no such thing as a risk free investment.
All investments carry risk, that’s kind
of why they generate a return in the first
place.
But, in the spectrum of risk, US government
bonds are as close as you’re gonna get when
it comes to minimizing risk.
In fact, the only time that a financial institution
is allowed to describe an investment as risk
free is when they’re referring to treasury
yields.
Treasury yields are considered “risk free”
because they’re backed by the US federal
government who in theory can just print money
to pay back bond holders.
When it comes to safety and security though,
the investment itself is only half the story.
The platform through which you invest is also
equally important and that’s why we’re
proud to say that each Silo account is protected
by $500,000 in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million
in FDIC insurance.
Also, all funds deposited on the platform
will be maintained by our trusted custodian,
Interactive Brokers, who has experience managing
$373 billion worth of assets over the past
45 years.
So, with Silo, you not only get the sleek
UI and friendly interface of a modern investing
platform but you also get the experience and
stability of an established brokerage.
All of that probably sounds nice and all,
but you’re probably wondering, how much
will all of this cost?
SILO PRICING
When it comes to investing, one key consideration
is cost.
When Robinhood entered the market back in
2014, they disrupted the market by cutting
commissions and fees, which played an important
role in the buzz they generated around trading.
However, as we found out, Robinhood still
makes money from your trades, just not transparently.
Instead, they use something called payment
for order flow which is essentially just a
hidden markup that’s built into the price
of the stock.
This is not only a frowned upon practice,
but a straight up illegal one in most countries
outside the US.
In fact, the EU just banned this practice
a couple of months ago.
The bond market doesn’t use payment for
order flow but bond brokers usually earn money
in a similar fashion: through markups.
For example, let’s say a given bond is trading
at $950.
To buy this bond, you’ll probably actually
have to pay $965 because the average bond
markup is $15.14.
And this applies when you’re selling as
well.
Instead of being subject to a markup though,
you’ll be subject to a markdown.
So, if a bond is trading for $950, you may
only be able to sell it for $935.
In other words, for every bond you buy and
sell, you would be losing $30 to markups and
markdowns.
At Silo, we wanted to make sure you don’t
have to worry about any costs while buying
bonds.
And that’s why we have absolutely no markups
or markdowns at Silo.
The execution fees for each order is also
passed on at cost.
How did we accomplish this, you ask?
Well, simple, by aligning our interests with
yours through a subscription fee.
Regardless of whether you buy only one bond
per month or are investing tens of thousands
on a daily basis, the price you see is the
price you pay.
The only way we make money is through a $10
subscription fee that is applied to accounts
that are larger than $3000.
As long as you buy at least 8 bonds per year,
the monthly fee will pay for itself.
Also, if you deposit less than $3000, the
platform is truly free to use.
Whether it's the bond prices themselves or
the execution fees, everything is passed on
at cost, we don’t make a dime.
Moreover, unlike other fintech platforms,
we’re not incentivized to get you to trade
because we make the same amount regardless
of how much you trade.
So, our goals are aligned: to make sure that
you make investing decisions that benefit
you over the long term.
With that being said, we would also like to
be honest about who this platform is actually
for because it’s not for everyone.
WHO SILO IS FOR:
While we’d love for as many of y’all to
use the platform, we think there is a certain
group of people who would benefit most from
Silo, while others would benefit more from
other investments, whether it be stocks, real
estate, indexes, or simply holding cash in
a savings account.
In today’s current rate environment, high
yield savings accounts are yielding rates
up to 5%, meaning that holding cash in a high-yield
savings account is a good option.
But what about cash that you have in a Chase
or Wells Fargo account?
Big banks are notorious for shilling out fractional
interest rates on your cash.
If you’re someone that’s holding cash
that isn’t benefiting from the high interest
rate environment or worse, getting eaten up
by high inflation, a good alternative is holding
short-term treasuries that provide rates as
high as 5.5%.
Also, if you’ve stockpiled a bunch of cash
into a high-yield savings account, one downside
you should consider is that high interest
rates savings accounts only last as long as
the fed keeps interest rates high.
In one, two, or a few years from now, decreases
in interest rates will send high-yield savings
rates back to the bottom.
So, if you don’t wanna play that game and
just wanna lock-in a rate for the next decade
or further, 10 or 30 year treasuries or even
long-term corporate bonds may make sense.
Ironically, this strategy may apply to the
other side as well.
For example, let's say you’re heavily invested
in stocks and are seeing that your returns
over the past year haven’t been that great
or want to reduce volatility.
Well then, it may be time to diversify.
Investing in bonds at these rates means earning
much more consistent and secure income that
has even matched stock market performance
over the past year.
Also, what about real estate?
With mortgage rates at levels past 8%, it
may make more sense to earn 5% through bonds
than pay 8% on a property.
Now a lot of these have to do with the condition
our economy is currently in.
One type of investor that may benefit from
bond investing regardless of current conditions
is a more conservative investor who has some
level of apprehension towards stocks.
Maybe, you see stocks as too risky, unpredictable,
and volatile but also feel that you should
be doing some sort of investing.
Well then, bonds could be the perfect middle
ground for you.
Sure, they wont have the same return potential
as stocks but it may be a more comfortable
investment.
As you can see, bonds can be a valuable asset
to a wide range of investors but to be frank
there’s a lot of people for whom bonds are
not the right choice.
WHO SILO IS NOT FOR:
Likely the most obvious group of people for
whom Silo would not be a good fit for is if
you’re not able to invest at least $5,000
or ideally at least $10,000.
For one, the monthly fee would eat into a
lot of your returns but even putting the fee
aside, bonds in general probably aren’t
a great fit for you.
For example, let’s say you invest $1000.
Even if you lock in a 8% yield, you’re only
earning $80 per year which brings up the question
of whether that’s even worthwhile.
It’s only when you get into the tens of
thousands that bond yields really start to
add up.
Also, if you’re not in a position where
you can invest $5 or 10,000, it would probably
be a better idea to build up larger cash reserves
and an emergency fund before investing in
anything.
Someone else that bonds may not be a good
fit for is someone who already has a solid
investing plan in place, and investing in
bonds would take away from that.
For example, maybe you already invest everything
you’re comfortable with investing into the
S&P 500 every month.
You should not start investing in bonds if
it would take away from this existing plan.
In other words, bond investing should be something
that you add to your investing strategy, not
something that replaces your existing strategy.
Bonds would also not be a good fit for you
if you have a high risk tolerance and are
looking for extraordinary returns.
The truth is that even if you’re investing
the highest yielding junk bonds, you won’t
be generating 5 or 10X returns, so if that’s
what you’re looking for and you’re willing
to take the risk, stocks and crypto would
probably be a better option.
Speaking of returns, since bonds pay a fixed
interest rate, there really is no compounding
effect.
When you try to reinvest your coupon payments,
there is no guarantee that bond yields will
be at the same level as when you originally
invested.
For example, a 30-year treasury bond today
yields around 5%.
But 10 years down the line, if 30 year treasuries
are only yielding 3%, you wouldn’t be able
to reinvest the interest payments at the same
5% yield.
So, if you want a single avenue to invest
into and see your cash compound, index funds,
ETFs, and mutual funds may make more sense.
Silo would probably also not be a good fit
for you if you have cash but can’t afford
to lock it up for a set period of time.
Aka, if you have a high need for liquidity,
investing in bonds is not the right choice
for you.
Rather, it would make more sense to keep your
money in a high-yield savings account without
a lock in period so that you can take it out
whenever you need.
Honestly, this is starting to sound like one
of those disclaimers at the end of a medicine
commercial, so let’s move on.
SILO:
At the end of the day, high inflation and
high interest rates have led us into an environment
that we haven’t seen since really the 1970s.
As such, the value proposition of every asset
class has drastically changed and the asset
class the likely benefited the most is fixed
income.
Of course we’re biased, but we believe that
we have created a stellar bond investing platform
that redefines how retail investors are able
to invest in bonds.
By choosing Silo, you’re choosing transparency,
ease of use, and most importantly, a wide
selection of secure and consistent investments.
So, if you’re in the market for something
like that, please consider checking out Silo
in the description below.
If it doesn’t really apply to you, we completely
understand and appreciate you watching the
entire video anyway.
If you would like to learn about how Microsoft
conquered the coding world, check out this
video.